الان نؤكد انه سقط سته شهداء فلسطينيين
على الاقل في قصف تم من خلال طائره حربيه
اسرائيليه قبل قليل كشف عن هؤلاء الشهداء
بعضهم مقطعه تقطعت اشلائه نتيجه هذا القصف
يتم نقلهم تباعا من خلال الطواقم الطبيه
وسيارات الاسعاف الى
مستشفيات المدينه لم يكن احد يعلم ان انه
خلال الساعات الماضيه صوت اطلاق النار من
قبل طائره حربيه اسرائيليه كان يستهدف هذا
التجمع للشبان الفلسطينيين تحديدا في مثلث
الشهداء وسط مدينه جنين بالطبع جاء ذلك
محمد عقب ان تمكن مقاومين فلسطينيين من
تفجير عبوات ناسفه وواضح انها كانت شديده
الانفجار في اليات عسكريه ما استطعنا رصده
اي سواء من مواقعنا او من خلال نشطاء بانه
على الاقل تم اعطاب اليتين عسكريتين
واحتاج جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى اكثر
من ثلاث ساعات لاخراج هذه الاليات من داخل
مدينه جنين بعد ادخال المزيد من التعزيزات
عبر حاجز الجلمه الى وسط مدينه جنين
وتحديدا الى حي الجابريات وايضا الى اطراف
مخيم جنين بالطبع هناك حاله من الصدمه
والذهول نتيجه هذا الكشف عن هؤلاء الشهداء
الذين واضح انهم سقطوا خلال الساع يعني
اقل شيء يمكن ان يكونوا قد سقطوا قبل ثلاث
ساعات لاننا سمعنا صوت اطلاق النار من
الطائره ونحن معكم على الهواء ولكن واضح
انه لم يكن احد يعلم ان هناك شهداء سقطوا
وان هناك ايضا جرحى لعدم وصول احد اليهم
الا بعد ان انسحب جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والاليات العسكريه من منطقه
مثلث الشهداء حتى هذه اللحظه لا زلنا
نستمع لبعض الاليات العسكريه وبالتالي لا
نتحدث عن انسحاب كامل من مدينه جنين
واطراف المخيم رغم ان الطواقم الط الطبيه
والطواقم الصحفيه تحاول الان التحرك و
التنقل وصولا الى المستشفى لكن لازال جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي موجود في اكثر من
موقع ولكن يبدو انه كوحدات خاصه او حتى قد
يكون من المستعربين اضافه الى امكانيه
وجود قناصه على اسطح المنازل لانه عاده
عندما يكون هناك انسحاب كامل لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يكون هناك رصد لعمليه
خروج الاليات على شكل صف واحد واحد متواصل
من الاليات العسكريه اتجاه حاجزي الجلمه
الشمالي مدينه جنين وايضا من المدخل
الجنوبي
لمدينه ولكن كما ذكرت لك حاله من الصدمه
والذهول من هذا العدد من الشهداء في دقائق
معدوده ولم يكن احد يعلم ان هناك بالفعل
شهداء وجرحى سقطوا ولكن ما نعيد ونؤكد في
هذا العاجل بانه وفق المصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه والطواقم الطبيه التي نقلت
شهداء وجرحى الى المستشفيات نتحدث عن سته
شهداء فلسطينيين بعضهم تقطعت اشلائه لم
تعرف هويه معظم الشهداء الان تم ادخالهم
الى الاماكن المخصصه في محاوله للكشف عن
هويه هؤلاء الشهداء وايضا كان هناك عدد من
الجرحى في هذه المنطقه كما ذكرت في منطقه
مثلث الشهداء وسط مدينه
جنين
ال مستشفى اذا الان تاكيد مدير مستشفى
جنين الحكومي يؤكد سقوط سته شهداء على
الاقل تم نقلهم الى مستشفى جنين الحكومي
جراء قصف
اسرائيلي تم وكما ذكرنا رايناه على الهواء
من خلال طائره اسرائيليه استمعنا الى صوت
اطلاق النار من
خلال الطائره التي كانت تحوم في الاجواء
بالطبع بالاضافه الى المسيرات العسكريه
التي لازالت ايضا تحوم في الاجواء حاله من
الصدمه والذهول لدى
الاهالي نفسه يعني ما طبيعه ما يجري الان
في في
جنين ك كما ذكرت لك محمد حتى الان لا
نستطيع القول ان هناك انسحاب كامل لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكن على الاقل في
المنطقه التي كنا عاده ما نغطي فيها وهي
من خلفنا ولا زلنا نرى حتى هذه اللحظه
سحابه دخان يعني نتحدث عن مرور خمس ساعات
حتى هذه اللحظه من سحابه الدخان هذه وهو
ذات الموقع الذي تم فيه تفجير البوات
الناسفه التي واضح انها شديده الانفجار في
الاليات العسكريه لا نستطيع ان نرصد اليات
عسكريه ولكن قد يكون هناك انسحاب تدريجي
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من المدينه
ولكن الخشيه تبقى لدى الاهالي والمقاومين
هو من بقاء وحدات خاصه في يعني متخفيه في
بعض الابنيه او المواقع او وجود قناصه على
اسطح عدد من المباني السكنيه ولكن ك يعني
على الارض ميدانيا لا يعني لا يمكن رؤيه
هذه الاليات العسكريه بشكل واضح ولكن مع
بقاء على الاقل مسيره واحده في السماء حتى
هذه اللحظه معناه انها لازالت تقوم
بالتغطيه على الاليات العسكريه الطائره
الحربيه او وفق شهود العيان ووفق الخبراء
من قام باطلاق هذا الرصاص من الطائره
وسقوط هذا العدد من الشهداء نتحدث كما
ذكرنا ووفق مدير مستشفى جنين الحكومه على
الاقل سقوط سته شهداء جاء بعد عمليه تفجير
العبوات ومعناه ان هذه الطائره جاءت
للتغطيه على عمليه سحب الاليات العسكريه
التي تم اعطاها واخراجها الى خ خارج مدينه
جنين بعض المواقع الاسرائيليه الغير رسميه
على الاطلاق ولا نتبنى اي شيء بانتظار
بيان رسمي من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بان
هذا هذه الانفجارات والتي كان دويها نسمعه
وهز مدينه جنين في اكثر من مره نتيجه هذه
العبوات الناسفه ننتظر بيان من الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان كان هناك اصابات في
صفوف لان عمليه اطلاق النار فور اعطاب
وتفجير العبوات الناسفه كان اطلاق نار
عشوائي وصف بانه هستيري ولكن يبدو ان من
خلال ما صدر من بيانات من فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وتحديدا من كتائب القسام شهداء
الاقصى وكتيبه جنين مجتمعه كانت قد اصدرت
بيان مشترك قبل حوالي الخمس الى ست ساعات
مع بدايه اقتحام الكامل لمدينه جنين بانها
تمكنت من تفجير عبوات ناسفه واطلاق النار
على الاليات العسكريه التي تم استهدافها
والتي كانت قد انتقلت من ما يعرف بدوار
عصفور اتجاه حي الجابريات وهي التله
المطله على مخيم جنين وايضا على اطراف
المخيم واندلعت اشتباكات ولكن واضح ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي تفاجا بكميه العبوات
الناسفه لانه فور دخول التعزيزات وامكانيه
اخراج هذه الاليات التي تم اعطاب تم ايضا
ادخال جرافه من نوع دي 9 هذه الجرافه تختص
تحديدا في تجريف الاراضي والشوارع
والطرقات ايضا
لنزع ابوات التي يكون المقاومون قد زرعوها
في اكثر من موقع اذا نتحدث حث عن الان
نقلا عن مسعف فلسطيني قام وكان من اول
الواصلين الى تلك المنطقه يقول نتحدث عن
مجزره نفذها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعد قصفه
مجموعه من الشبان جنوبي جنين اذا نتحدث عن
تاكيد من مدير مستشفى جنين الحكومي عن
سقوط سته شهداء على الاقل عن مسعف يصف
المم شد بانه اشبه بمجزره وايضا عن تاكيد
اعطاب مقاومين لاليات عسكريه على الاقل
نتحدث عن اليتين وسط مدينه جنين وتحديدا
في حي الجابريات واطراف المخيم